Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, and this is episode 12 long overdue.
I think the last episode I made was in November of last year.
And my staff told me the other day that you really need to do an update of how you're doing.
We had somebody call today and wonder if you were still alive.
So I, like Mark Twain, must say the reports of my death have been greatly exaggerated.
I am still alive very well.
Thank you very much.
But in truth, back in October, November, we had a little trip planned after Christmas.
And quite honestly, I wasn't quite sure if I was going to be gone or going on that trip at least.
Wasn't sure how I was going to be feeling because I was feeling really, really horrible.
And felt like I was slipping downhill pretty fast.
So, but God in his grace, in his mercy, has kept me here.
And Dom kind of put me in a remission the last couple months.
So I feel so much better than I did then.
So I have days like today that I felt horrible again.
And Dom just kind of goes with the territory.
But all in all, praise God, I'm doing better.
So he wants to be around here for some reason or another,
and we're just going to keep moving forward.
But I want to share not just that update.
I want to share what's on my heart, what's been on my heart.
So this is kind of what God is teaching me.
So this little message that I've titled, I'm no hero,
is about kind of my mistakes in my journey in life,
in my journey with my walk, with my savior.
So let's jump right into it.
This is how I usually read my Bible.
I read a Bible story, and I assert myself as the hero in the story.
So I read the story, and I relate to the victor.
Maybe that's a human tendency.
Maybe we all do it.
I don't know, I'm just sharing you what I do.
So I read a story about Moses versus Pharaoh,
and I'm relating to Moses.
And I'm dealing with all the Pharaohs, the doubters,
the ones that are coming against me,
the ones that God hardened their heart against his work.
And I'm the Moses trying to stand steadfast in what God has said
and what God has done, and I'm coming against all these evil doers
and all these evil people that are coming against the work of God.
And I read stories about Moses versus the rebellious Israelites.
My family, we've challenged all our kids who gave them
a one year Bible this year, and I'm such an auditory learner.
I've been listening to the Bible, and I love listening to somebody
with an English accent.
So I'm listening to this, I can't remember the guy's name,
who is a new King James, or King James version,
but it's just beautiful listening to his English accent,
to Old English, wonderful, and went through all of Deuteronomy
and all of Exodus and the first five books of the Bible
and the Old Testament so far.
And you just wonder, you just hit your head against the wall,
like, how can these people be so blasted ignorant?
They were widening because they didn't have any food,
and God fed them daily with mana, sent from heaven.
They didn't have to work for it.
All they had to do was gather, and they could only gather
enough for today, or go bad.
Then they'd start widening that they didn't have water,
and God gave them water for the stone,
poured out and fed the millions.
But as soon as another crisis came, they would win,
and then God would provide, and then another crisis would come
and they would win, and God would provide.
And so often I go, oh my gosh, how are these people so dense-minded?
Why, no wonder God called them the stiff-necked Israelites,
because they would not see the big picture.
And I want to say, well, I'm like Moses,
I see the big picture, but it's really easy to read that
from hindsight.
And I want to assert myself as the victor,
the one who's leading the rebellious Israelites,
and I would never be a rebellious Israelite.
Or Abraham versus Lot.
Abraham, stalwart, solid in his faith,
and yet Lot was willing to move to Sodom,
and live in such filth and ungodliness,
because it profited him.
And I would never do that.
I'm more like Abraham, as I want to read myself,
as the hero, the victor in the Bible.
I could give you a hundred examples.
David versus Goliath is probably the most common.
How many pastors have preached on David versus Goliath?
And you have to stand up against your Goliaths.
There's maybe dozens of Christian books on how
to overcome your Goliath.
Why? Because we Christians want to read ourselves
into the victors of the Bible.
I'm like David, and I'm coming against these people
that are stronger than me, and bigger than me,
and taller than me, and more mighty than me,
and yet I could defeat them, because I have gone on my side,
and I see myself as David, fighting my Goliaths.
And I want to be like Jesus, and be struggling against the scribes
and the Pharisees, and that's the way I want to see myself.
But how should I really assert myself into the Bible?
How I usually need to read my Bible is that I need to assert myself
as the villain.
I'm not Moses against Pharaoh.
Most of the time, I'm Pharaoh against the will of God.
I'm the one who's hard deed by heart against what God is trying to teach me.
I'm the rebellious Israelite.
God provides for me day after day after day.
His mercies are new every day.
He forgives my sins on a daily basis.
And yet I continue to walk away from Him and distrust Him.
It's easy to do when we're in good times,
and it's just as easy to do when we're in bad times.
We are the faithless individuals, not trusting God's ways.
We whine and cry because we don't get our way
because we don't feel the greatest.
We didn't get the best diagnosis from the doctor.
Our CT scan didn't come out better.
Our MRI is showing a worse side of the cancer.
Our boss is not recognizing my talents
and we act like the rebellious Israelites of the Bible.
What if we read our Bible differently?
I'm challenging myself this year as I go through my Bible again this year
to read myself into the villain of the Bible
because that's really honestly how I act most of the time.
I'm the lot that would be willing to live in a worldly place for my own gain.
Not to witness the people and not to bring people to God.
How many people did lot bring to God?
Done. How many people were saved out of Sodom?
But lot, it is two daughters, even his wife turned back.
So he wasn't there for a godly purpose.
He was there for selfish purposes and how often is that me?
I'm not the David fighting against the evil Goliath.
I'm the evil Goliath who's rebelling against God
with God's ways and mocking God's ways,
even though all the while I say I'm a mighty warrior.
I am the scribes in the Pharisees
who nitpick God's word in order to make myself look better
while I overlook the Savior
who's trying to bring grace and mercy into my life
and other people's life.
So what I need to do is move from art I great
to really I need God.
When I see myself as the villain in the Bible
instead of the victor in the Bible, I'm in greater need.
I realize the need that I have for a Savior
versus me being the Savior.
It's so easy especially in our American culture
to get into this Jesus complex
because we have so many things and so much stuff
that we are our own Savior.
We really don't need God and we're using God
and Christianity for our own good,
not for a purpose of growing deeper in our walk with Him
in a greater need for Him.
I need to move from art I great to boy
told I have a great need for God.
I have a greater need for God.
And as I read my Bible, I need to say
I need to break me to the point where I see my sin
and it brings me to a greater dependence upon Him.
I need to move from a look what I deserve
to praise God.
I didn't get what I deserve.
This is a big one for a lot of people.
It's a big one for me too.
You could easily fall and do a trap of whitey
and look at all I did for you God.
Look at all I'm doing to try to serve you.
Look at all I'm trying to do to help people.
You gave me this cancer.
I have to deal with this too
and this is just a barricade.
This is not fair
and I can wipe it and I can cry all I want.
But really if God was going to give me what I truly deserve,
I'd spend eternity in hell.
And I don't deserve another breath.
I don't deserve another day.
It's only by His great mercies
that my cells are functioning today.
And it is getting to that point
that is the fight that we all have to have.
You've heard it said that we need to move
from being a victim to a victor.
There's a famous preacher we could say that kind of coined that term.
We need to be the victor, not the victim.
I agree that we don't need to be the victim.
There's no benefit to stay in the victim.
But I'll tell you that being the victim,
we need to move to understanding that we are the villain
and that there's only victory
while I'm holding on to the victor.
Jesus Christ is our victor.
I'm not the victor.
And I can only experience that victory when I'm holding on to Him.
And I can only hold on to Him when I move into that state of repentance
because I realize that my relationship with God is only
bedded by forgiveness.
And it's only bedded by repentance.
So that's the first place.
We don't move from victim to victor.
We move from victim to realizing that we are the villain
and that there's only victory that I have
is holding on to Jesus Christ.
I said about October, November last year
I was doing pretty poorly health wise.
I was feeling like I was slipping downhill quickly
and quite honestly though we were making family plans
to go away to Florida for a week's vacation
the few days after Christmas for a week,
honestly in the back of my mind
because I would say that I'm a pessimist.
I certainly am not that.
I would exactly call myself an optimist though.
I'd call myself more of a realist.
So I feel like I can honestly look at a situation
and be a realist about it and go,
this is what it is and this is what it is.
And at that time I felt like what it was
as far as how I was feeling in the progression of my cancer
and I wasn't quite sure that I was going to make it on that trip.
Either I was not going to be here anymore
or I was going to be way too sick to travel.
It was about that time that God put,
you know, people who know me,
I love to read and listen to books and all the time.
God put a book in front of me that I'd recommend to a lot of you.
It's a book by one of my favorite authors, NT Wright,
called Surprised by Hope.
And God had quite honestly,
lots of times God has me read a book
because of just a few little tidbits in a book.
And a few tidbits that I got out of NT Wright's Surprised by Hope
was that we need to focus on what God has for us now.
But what the Holy Spirit was teaching me through this
is to get my eyes off of my cancer,
off of my diagnosis and just get my eyes on him.
So that I could just walk in that victory
and it's the victory that God has for me.
Don't try to define your own victory.
I have patients all the time
that they have such a focused view of their victory
and it's that they're cured of cancer.
And my comment is,
who says that's your victory?
Paul didn't see his victory,
talking about the Apostle Paul,
he didn't see his victory as being released by Caesar.
Well, he didn't get released by Caesar.
He got his head chopped off.
He saw his victory as his purpose of life,
which was to be a witness to everybody
that he came in contact with.
He saw his victory is to be able to preach another day
in Caesar's household.
He saw his victory is to see people come to Christ
into a knowledge of the truth through what he was saying.
He didn't see his victory as some selfish gain
of living longer,
of getting a new boat,
or getting some new tip-making equipment
so he could do his job better.
He saw his victory as fulfilling his purpose on earth.
And that's the tidbit that I got out of this book also.
And I need to see what my purpose is on earth here
and that's my victory.
So I just got to work.
By wife and I took a trip,
a couple of weekend little getaways,
and I think it was October.
And I was feeling really lousy.
We took a drive down just through Iowa and southern Wisconsin.
It was just absolutely stunningly gorgeous
with scenery that we saw.
But driving was very difficult
because every little bump I just had,
so much pain in my gut,
it was a struggle.
And through that,
God was teaching me something.
I talked to my wife about this.
It was great having that time off,
and it was wonderful,
spending time with the love of my life.
But God just revealed to me,
I need to get back to work.
I just cannot take time off of work.
There's other role of going on vacation
and sharpening your saw.
I took a week off after Christmas.
And it was wonderful.
And we all need to do that.
But my main purpose has to get back
to what God has me for.
That is to be a doctor to my patients
and to be constantly digging and searching
and writing and helping and serving.
Because that's just the purpose that God has for me.
And my comment to my patients
would be, look and see what God's purpose is for you.
Because yes, you should do what you need to do
to overcome the burden of what you have going on,
the cancer, the sickness, the life,
the whatever you're dealing with right now.
But if that is your purpose in life,
you miss the boat.
You're off the mark.
You are running the wrong race.
And we do not want to be guilty of missing the mark.
The mark is not to be cured of your cancer.
If that is your purpose in your life to be cured of cancer,
you are running the wrong race, bro.
You are totally off-game.
Your purpose in life is to serve God
and to break him glory in whatever channel he has you in.
And if it is through you getting over your cancer,
well, that's great.
If it is through you dying of cancer, well, I'm sorry.
But that's great too.
And I will need to die for cancer while I walk in my victory,
which is serving him and bringing him glory if that's what he chooses.
And if he chooses me to live longer, then that's great too.
I'll just continue to serve him.
That's the piece that I got out of this book.
And it just drove me back to work again just to keep my focus there.
Not on working to cure my cancer, but working to help my patients
and help others and bring the truth of him and to bring him glory through serving him.
And that's what I want for you to.
So that's my prayer for you guys today that you come to your victory
by hanging on to the victor and him revealing to you
what your ultimate purpose is is to serve him.
Not to cure cancer, not to solve your financial problems,
not to overcome your struggles, not to cure your whatever.
Problems in your life are there for a purpose to reveal to you
that you need to hold on more dearly to him.
And that's my prayer for you.
Thanks for listening.
Love you all.
Bye-bye.